fear anything I say we're in the green
room before the streamys just got here
the morning look who else is arrived I'm
Chrissy Chrissy you look like an angel
and Andrews here too my gosh everyone
seemed really excited we're going to the
script and then we're gonna go do some
rehearsals and Hannah and I both were at
very similar outfits today you know you
know what they say what have friends
that dress together hosts best together
oh hey guys sunglasses inside pitbull
here is here so we are backstage it is
what time is it I know um time to get
real it's 10:00 you guys it may look
like it's like the wee hours of the
morning but it's actually like 10:30
yeah yeah yeah it feels like it's like
4:00 a.m. right now that we've been up
all night getting ready no we're getting
ready for what the shammies we're
backstage in our green room right now
glamorous glamorous glamorous before we
got here apparently the power will
resolve so the powers come back on which
is a great start I think that power is
probably like one of the first things I
would yeah so like we're getting there
we're getting ready on stage to do
rehearsal hello it's one way look at the
stage it's beautiful everyone's here the
lighting looks great her makeup is done
we're ready
licensing here's our pre-show meal hello
yeah I post my face apart we're getting
ready a weird party how close goodbye to
the other side oh look at this beauty
happening right now what me oops
I'm just putting coal weird chemicals
into my eye ducts right before we go on
stage yeah that's the Miriam Weber
definition of being a lady can I just
say I feel more awake possibly because I
have these things sucking under my eyes
yeah possibly
okay we're still in the process of hair
makeup haniss where are you there you
are
getting some stuff done over there I
just got my nails done Elizabeth did
them but then I smeared the mixes too
excited because Tara Reed is now
following me on Twitter if she fell on
you Hanna my shaggy
okay take your time she's follow me on
Twitter and little does she know there's
a sweet sweet joke about her in the
opening monologue but this is very
exciting hey it's cinder it's not even
at her expense it's at a production's
expense that she was involved in we have
an hour so I switched immediately to
sweatpants and a t-shirt I'm just going
to sit here and reevaluate second-guess
all the jokes that we'll be making in
the opening monologue fine
are you filming me no I'm just doing a
panning photo oh okay breakfast of
champions after the Streamy Awards money
we're in the house but getting internet
installed today yay yes also I didn't
show you guys Lauren the realtor who
helped me find this house as a
housewarming gift she got me this look
at all this amazing stuff it's all stuff
to start a bar she know me she know me
she does Smith is that good
I just put curtains up and I'm really
proud of myself I'm just gonna let this
light wash all over me and I'm gonna
feel really proud of myself for doing
that only put them up upside down once
fixed it now they're great also I went
to Target again guys I friend IKEA came
over I have nighttime activities let's
do it
it's Thursday and I'm sick greatest
update of all time some might say some
I've never experienced real excitement
in their lives update I put this
headband on because when you don't feel
well me just get desperate I did want to
mention that the represent calm / its
grace the the limited-edition shirts
that were available I have not clothes
and you guys bought three thousand of
them I set the goal at five hundred
because I had no idea I haven't really
had its grace merch officially yet and
and you guys bought three thousand which
is awesome and I think you're really
gonna like the shirts because for pretty
da-da-dah yeah they're really pretty and
cute and I'm really happy with them and
um I want to know from you guys if
that's something you're interested in I
was thinking about like instead of
opening up just
merch store which I've done in the past
and works decent I get really finicky
about my merch and sometimes I make it
and I don't like it after it's out that
I thought this is kind of a fun way that
once a month or once every other month
to create like one very cool piece of
merch that I really really love and
offer it to you guys
for a limited run now I'm just talking
so much this is a headband I'm I feel
like my words are worth listening to it
this headband I guess I'm going to
attempt to make a smoothie because then
you feel not good you get desperate
great job
that seems good I'm not going to trust
it that seems great Oh
party time
oh my god I think I did it oh my god
tastes like a thing tastes like all the
things I put in it but not solid it was
Friday I haven't changed much because
still slightly under the weather but a
little bit better I'm at the house I'm
gonna be calling it the house from now
on because it's just easier to say I
don't know if I showed you guys this
other night look I put that whole couch
together right yelling that iconic yeah
I'm going for a real rustic look I got a
package in the mail that I think is
something that I think is cool whoa I'm
very strong when I need to be it's an
updated bound manuscript it's still not
that it's a letter from my editor really
sweet okay it's not the full book yet
it's cuz if I look doesn't look like
this or like this but it's an update
every time bookmarks for me to sign to
give to you guys remember guys go to
Grace's guide book comm from now until
the release of the book and enter the
Grace's guide sweepstakes or so for 600
prizes and every week we're giving away
I think ten signed book marks despise
yep that that look like this and I'm
gonna be signing these and giving these
to you guys to make sure you go to
grayscale book check out hey I thought I
was gonna be the final final book not
yet so this is just a little floor
plague I don't know